check this out hi drew today i'm going
to show you how to make this diy slot
wall
you'll first cut out your slots from
large sheets of plywood we went with the
slots being one inch wide but this is
all based off of preference
next we painted the wall tricorn black
by sherwin williams before attaching the
slots then we clamped the slots together
and painted the edges because this is
much easier than painting within the
gaps after they're hung
now it was finally time to attach the
slots to the wall we use the spacer to
have consistent gaps and attach them
using two inch brad nails we angled the
nails in alternating directions so they
crossed in the wall and secured the
slats
once that was complete we filled all the
nail holes with wood filler and sanded
them down to prep for paint
we wanted the slots to blend in so we
painted them the same color we used on
the wall
finally we hung these sconces and
instead of going through the hassle of
hard wiring we used the puck light
then we added a desk and turned it into
a small office space to enjoy